united as rarely before the west has
fired off one salvo of economic
sanctions after another in response to
vladimir putin's attack on ukraine
sending the ruble plummeting and
citizens rushing to withdraw their
savings from russian banks
so far that has prompted no let up in
the fighting
now the united states are upping the
pressure banning oil imports from russia
calls for europe to follow suit are
growing louder but countries like
germany fear that could harm citizens
and industry yet that pain could pale
compared to the looming food crisis
caused by the shortage of wheat from
ukraine unto the point we ask sanctions
against putin could they [ __ ] the
global economy
[Music]
pleasure to welcome our guests katya
gloga is an expert on eastern europe and
former moscow and washington
correspondent for the german weekly uh
magazine dear stan
and it's a pleasure to have with us
vandaline fundraido she is the european
business and finance correspondent for
the british magazine the economist based
here in berlin
and i'm very glad that my colleague
vladimir espinoff can join us sorry
vladimir essipof of course
he is with our russian desk here at dw
great to have you with us as well
and vladimir i'd like to go straight to
you to know what you're hearing from
friends and relatives in russia how much
pain are the sanctions causing
and there's no much pain right in the
moment but there is a very very big
fears about what
else can can
come to russia because in the last two
weeks we saw
many achievements of the russian economy
of the russian businessmen just
collapsing in fro
before in front of our eyes so many many
things which were built up in russian
business the russian economy just gone
in the last two weeks so starting today
the credit cards mastercard and visa
does not do not work in russia anymore
mcdonald's left coca-cola left so the
people are just irritating they're
trying to cope with this new reality
i've talked yesterday to someone in
moscow
who is a friend of mine a former
colleague from my previous job and uh
she is very afraid the in in the office
where the salary
decrease reduction were announced by 20
and the people is just starting to have
some fears about their professional
future today i spoke to someone in saint
petersburg in my hometown who is quite
concerned as well there's no food
shortages there are no panic on the
streets there are no use in front of the
atms but there is a very strong sense of
some something which can be
really worse in the weeks and months to
come it seems that numerous younger and
well-educated russians are now leaving
the country i actually know of a couple
of cases within my own circle of friends
can you confirm that and what impact
will that have on the country
as far as i know the capital of armenia
yerivan is packed with young russians
professionals new yappies and
journalists arriving from saint
petersburg in moscow the flights are
full there's dozens 20 to 25 flights
daily arriving from russian cities to
armenia alone i've hearing stories of
people who are trying to get out of
russia via
via armenia georgia and then further to
europe the people are desperate to get a
visa for the european union to flee
russia
it's it's a huge movement of young smart
wrestler-minded people from the country
right now
vindalin many of us had thought before
this war began that russia had sanction
proofed the economy since 2014. it has
seen successive rounds of sanctions uh
since the annexation of the crimea
and yet apparently that sanction
proofing hasn't worked so well why
well because the sanctions that we are
being deployed now are not uh much much
bigger stronger mightier than whatever
we did after the uh annexation of the
crimea
um for instance that we cut off russia
from the swiss the swift payment system
which is for international transfers we
didn't do that in the past the fact that
russia cannot access its um foreign
currency reserves they have about 600
billion dollars in foreign reserves but
but they're being frozen so you know
that's something we haven't done in the
past the west hasn't done in the past so
what's being unleashed is is
incomparably bigger than what we did in
the past and will vladimir putin's new
friend xi jinping will he be able to
make up for some of this isolation in
terms of providing perhaps more trade
an alternative payment system and so on
yes he will of course and he will try to
do so and that's the danger in in in
what the west is doing right that we
further
basically um incite russia to get closer
to china but i think that's a risk worth
taking in order to defend ukraine
and uh katya uh
as i i said when i introduced you you
know eastern europe well you know uh
russia uh and it was clear from your
conversation before this show that you
also do speak russian so also to you the
question about the impact that this is
having on normal citizens and whether
you think that will make any difference
to vladimir putin because autocrats of
course don't have to really pay
attention to public opinion
yeah when it comes to the economical and
social situation in russia we've seen
this since years what vladimir is
mentioning is happening now to an even
larger extent
that young western oriented innovative
creative people so all the people you
need to modernize the country and to to
show away into a good future for a
country
that they are leaving we had tens of
thousands of people scientists
entrepreneurs
creative people leaving russia already
will that make a difference to vladimir
putin
adding to the modernization blockade the
country is facing since many years
to vladimir putin
it will not make a difference today but
it will
it might make a big difference tomorrow
the day after tomorrow because
the
sanctions package
the west united has never
unleashed against the russian economy
and
against putin's oligarchs
will send
the economy crippling i mean there have
been predictions i think for morgan
stanley in american bank um that um
russia might default within a couple of
months already
what would that mean actually and and
would putin feel the effects of that a
default insolvency
i mean if the economy is
crashing
um it will have huge consequences for
the for the country for trade and
and everything
will it cause
political unrest political
demonstrations will it cause
revolutions or say of the oligarchs
turning against him
it's way too early to say from what i
hear
at least from
my russian friends is that they are you
know
in a situation between total shock and
total disbelief
um and
are very much afraid to
go on the street vladimir let me ask you
about those sanctions that target
oligarchs obviously the idea is to
get to putin through them
do you think that will work
that will not work because oligarchs has
no influence on putin oligarchs as a
as a word from the beginning from the
first two terms of putin's charms in the
president in the beginning of 2000 years
now oligarchs are not a part of the
russian political system they are not
any they have no any political influence
i have so one of them on
on
british tv couple couple of days ago and
he was like fearing for his life and
jittering the voice but there is no
chance that the oligarch can influence
the political decisions of vladimir
putin not at all and it's it's said that
putin is increasingly in a bubble that
the people closest to him are security
elites uh and that he
it's hard to know what information he
actually receives what would he
presumably know about the situation of
the economy and how much difference
would it make to him do you think
um
look
[Music]
we all hear and
see the same information from moscow we
all hear and see that putin is in a
bunker somewhere on the ground hiding
from from the daylight and
making some
um quite strange looking meetings with
his ministers on a very long table
when putin sitting on the one end of
this table and to minister of the
defense sitting on another end of the
table which looks quite strange we don't
really know which kind of information he
gets on which channels he is being
informed as far as we know that the
channels are very limited so it's a very
limited sources of information what he
is getting
but once again the question is
now which
pain and which
changes the economical crash and it's
i'm would talk about the economic crash
in russia because the amount of
sanctions in the the strength of these
sanctions are crashing crushing russian
economy i would ask myself which to
which degree is russian society is ready
to adapt to the new reality and how
will this adaptation will go away how's
your answer what's your answer to that
question
um
i have no answer is any russian we are
just speechless since two weeks we are
just
just liking words we just looking into
the future fearing for future but no one
has an answer because no one knows
what's next no one would expect that
russia would invade the neighborhood
country where so many russians have
friends and relatives so no one
would even dare to make any prognosis
for the next week and i would not do it
at all
neither
vendelina recent editorial by your
magazine the economist pointed out that
sanctions are a long game and that they
inevitably involve trade-offs saying
that we could even see a rollback of
globalization uh from uh
the the current dynamic and that that in
fact could uh could stop uh the process
that has taken many many people all over
the world out of poverty
when you look at it that way would you
say that the potential benefits of these
harsh sanctions that we're seeing that
they don't necessarily justify the risks
it's hard to say these are uncharted
waters right i mean we have never
unleashed sanctions like that as
vladimir says what we did you know in
2014-15 is it's nothing compared to what
we're doing now in particular now that
the u.s is stopping imports of gas and
oil from russia
as i mentioned this in swift the
international payment system i mean
everything that we announced in the last
video it will crush the russian economy
i mean forecaster that gdp will go down
by 35 percent this year
in the second quarter and by seven
percent for the entire year that's
that's a lot that's worse than the
financial crisis in 2008
and and and vladimir was saying you know
we don't really feel it yet but very
soon in particular the russian middle
class will feel you know the effect very
very painful there will not be any
russian any middle class left sorry to
interrupt you there will be no such
russian middle uh class left they will
be all uh the the the country will
decrease or the fall in the poverty on a
very huge basis so i would not talk
about any middle class in russia let us
let us look at
the calls now to ratchet up pressure
even further the u.s this week cut off
its oil imports from russia let's hear
why
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine americans of rallied support
have rallied to support the ukrainian
people and made it clear we will not be
part of subsidizing putin's war
[Music]
katya calls for europe to follow suit
are in fact growing
louder now here in germany one of the
first actions that were taken by the
government was to suspend operation of
the nordstrom 2 pipeline bringing
russian gas straight to germany but that
wasn't in operation yet so did that
really make any difference
it was
an important political step because it
gave the signal that there is a real
turn um in german
policy towards russia but with no effect
on our
you know on the deliveries of of gas and
oil what we see though
um
that the markets react also to president
biden's
announcement so
gas prices are skyrocketing we pay more
than two euro per liter of gasoline
already
and there certainly is the political
fear of social unrest
um if prices prices
would soar if we would suspend north
stream one and this is the discussion we
are facing now by the way putin himself
has talked about uh
shutting down shipments through
nordstream one nordstrom two one of
course being the other pipeline that
brings gas to europe
what likelihood do you think there is
that we are going to see a cutoff of gas
supply to europe either from one side or
the other it very much depends i think
on the situation on the ground in
ukraine how the war is going on and what
putin
is ready um to do or not to do
the pressure the political pressure the
moral pressure in the very end will
will go up if he doesn't stop or if
there's no solution
um to be found and in the very end it
comes down to this very simple question
we cannot do
nothing
okay and we're going to drill deeper on
that point but let me ask vandaline to
tell us a little bit about what these
soaring oil prices mean in the way of
pain for example in the u.s and i'm
talking about uh political as well as
economic pain the u.s is a country very
dependent on the automobile you are
right and and in in that sense i'm at my
i admire president biden for taking that
step because it may hurt him politically
you know the gas prices are uh prices
for um petrol are going up a lot you
know and that's not popular
i mean he will try to compensate for it
right i mean i know there are talks with
the united arab emirates with with lots
of countries that can increase their
production of oil but you cannot make up
for it so quickly um the us gets about
10 percent of its oil from
russia so it's substantial but it's not
it's not as much as the european union
which is about a quarter right talk to
us about that part of it
europe is far more dependent on russian
gas than the us is dependent on russian
oil so what would happen if europe were
to follow the u.s example
it's very hard to imagine because europe
imports 40 percent of its gas of its
natural gas from from russia and a
quarter 15 um
25 percent of its um of its oil
to just shut cut that off from one day
to the other i'm not entirely sure how
that that could work okay now that the
coldest months are over so you know
maybe over the summer we could find
alternative routes more and that's what
the eu commission says it says it has
built up now additional reserves fearing
uh what could happen and that they will
get us through uh the summer but yes but
then there's the winter coming and the
winter might be harsh
i think it it it is probably possible
but it will be very hard vladimir uh two
questions uh to you starting with the
effect on russia so you've told us the
effects that the sanctions so far uh the
the the impact
that you're seeing what would happen if
europe were now to say we're cutting off
gas
look i i think it's just too early to
talk about it because the goal of the
sanctions is not to punish russia as a
goal but to stop this war and as soon as
this war will be stopped the sanctions
should be taken back step by step so i
think we are talking yet we are talking
now long-term
like end of this year about possible
possible cutoff of the russian gas and
oil deliveries to europe but it could be
that the war will be stopped much
earlier in the next weeks or months so
the whole
the whole topic of the cutting russians
oil and gas deliveries in in you to
europe in the end of this year might be
not any more
any more actual
let me ask you this uh let me ask you
this uh because you know of course uh
germany europe very well what's your
reading of public opinion here do you
think people here
would withstand the hardship
that a gas
cut off from european side potentially
would cause meaning
cold houses uh
possibly uh having to go without other
things comforts
i'm so busy to just to digest what the
people in the ukraine just doing and
what hardship the people in ukraine
experiencing right now there's no cold
house houses in the ukraine the houses
are being destroyed there is no uh
discomfort like
two dollars per berlin gas on benzene
and diesel it's just
blown the tank stations are being fi on
fire the whole country in the ukraine is
on fire so i'm i'm just struggling to
talk about the hardships in europe i
understand compared to the hardships
which ukrainian people suffering right
then let me tell you back to your
questions let me ask you when you say
that does that mean you think that this
back door that the eu left open in its
sanctions package allowing energy
deliveries to continue do you think that
should be
shut what
what we're seeing right now that russia
since the beginning of the in so-called
special military preparation in ukraine
russia is increasing gas deliveries
through the yamaha europa pipeline so
the
whole issue with the decreasing russian
deliveries
in the last months before the special
military operation operation in the
russian warding now russia
sending more and more gas to europe
it might be a signal from the russian
government that russia is ready to
deliver more gas to europe it's very
interesting signal it's not being talked
much about it but i'm reading this on
the russian news that the gas prom
sending more gas to europe via this
pipeline
let me just add if i my two very quick
points the first one is uh german
politics and german society which has
been
which has shown real solidarity with the
ukrainian people and the fate of the
ukrainian people
um
so far and former federal president
joham gauguig yesterday said
it might be worth freezing a little
for freedom
[Music]
so this is a discussion
we will face in our country and then
there's
in my eyes the very important political
sign from the european union including
germany to finally finally get
independent of russian
or at least oil and gas deliveries
and thereby also showing that the old
mantra of you know change through trade
bundle to handle in in german that this
was fiction in respect to putin i want
to take us back to the global situation
because that of course was part of the
title of our show and when it comes to
hardship shortages of a very different
commodity could spark an even greater
global crisis ukraine is the world's
fifth largest wheat exporter planting
season is beginning but many farmers are
at war
in war torn yemen the wheat reserves
will last for another couple of months
according to the government
but many like here in the capital city
of sanaa worry about the rising prices
for flour
the ukrainian russian war will affect
the whole world and not just us this war
will affect import export and trade
because we we're an importer of wheat
and most of the foodstuffs are from
abroad so undoubtedly we will be
affected
lebanon says it has wheat reserves for
just one more month
the country's largest silos were
destroyed at an explosion in beirut in
2020 the country depends on wheat
imports with 60 percent coming from
ukraine
turkey depends on wheat imports from
russia the country is in the midst of an
economic crisis with sky-high inflation
there have been massive protests over
rising food prices
many turks fear that the war will make
matters worse
and basic food items
even more expensive
vandaling inflation food shortages it's
all troublingly reminiscent of the 1930s
when global economic instability helped
pave the way for the second world war
could we see a similar collapse of the
global economy uh this time around or is
this time different
i i hope not i think this time is
different um
first of all i'm i'm hoping this this
will be not be a long war that that that
and and that that as vladimir said then
the sanctions will be rolled back one by
one
um we will see a spike in the price of
wheat we're already seeing that and
that'll that that that's a big problem
because um
and there are not many alternatives at
the moment to ukrainian and russian
wheat
but i hope we are not headed for the
1930s again
and vladimir to you because you you you
told us it's hard to look uh as far down
the road as uh the end of this year
but you seemed to imply that you see
chances for the war uh to end before
that um but none of them none of the
peace talks that we're seeing so far are
delivering results
but russia cannot afford this war to
take place like for one or two months
anymore because it's once it's
it's
russia in two weeks doesn't achieve
didn't achieve the military goals on the
on the ground there's a growing sense of
fears in the russian society about the
young soldiers who are obviously being
either killed in the ukraine or taking
prisoners in the ukraine so it's a very
urgent sense of emergency in the russian
society is spreading more and more
and for economic situation in russia
will be in two three four weeks or
two or three months
on such crack in crisis
situation that russia will
be pushed to stop this war somehow
katya our title asks whether sanctions
will [ __ ] the global economy is there
a risk that the war could
in general could [ __ ] the global
economy to the point that it creates
more instability rather than less i very
much hope that financial institutions
and political leaders are
more up to the task now i could also
hope and imagine when it comes to the
economic consequences for a country like
china
that china and putin's new friend and
strategic partner xi jinping would weigh
in thank you very much thanks to all of
you for being with us and thanks to our
viewers for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you